macron il arrive au dernier moment là
ils vont peut-être en trouver un autre
mais à chaque fois ils on trouve donc
tous les pays du monde on a éludé petit
macron qui sortait de rien et qui était
portée par un système oligarchique
vous verrez dans la dernière semaine de
la campagne présidentielle nous aurons
graves incidents ça a été mais ras en
ça a été l'attentât dernières semaines
sur les champs elysées vous rappeler de
tout ça c'était la dernière semaine donc
tout ça c'est écrit d'avancé
nous allons présenter chapeau nous
aurons les événements gravissimes qui va
une fois de plus permettent de montrer
du doigt les musulmans et d'inventer une
guerre civile
voilà ali baddou mais moi c'est doux
c'est pas possible pour le réveiller un
moment on se fout et le cil est pas
choqué c'est parce qu'il est juste pas
choqué parce qu a pas de quoi être
choqué ou les je vous dise ça vous
voulez je vous dise à quel ça des
services jean luc meynot faire qu il ne
relance pas s'il a le relancer pour
cette qu'il aurait pu préciser mais mais
mais ce qui présentait la part jean luc
mélenchon a déjà été présenté sur
l'antenne de france info par des
chercheurs des voilà donc il ya vraiment
pas de nouveauté et c'est tout à fait
normal c'était tous les noms mais moi je
suis absolument sidéré par leur défense
presque à la limite on peut dire mes
paroles ont dépensé ma pensée non non la
défense de jean luc mélenchon s'est
ainsi d'insulter ceux qui ont été
choqués alors de deux choses l'une
peut-être je veux bien entendre
aujourd'hui après avoir lu ces
explications qu'il ne voulait pas dire
que les attentats eux mêmes étaient une
invention du système mais qu'il voulait
dire que c'était leur surmédiatisation
m'a alors fait tout à fait
extraordinaire parce que en mars 2012
pendant les trois jours durant lesquels
on ne savait pas qui était mohamed merah
et que toute la gauche et l'extrême
gauche je rêvais pourvu que ce soit
breivik français il ya même un
journaliste du nouvel obs qui l'a twitté
si vous voulez alors là jean luc
mélenchon a parlé alors là il est allé
il y est allé de ses déclarations
et c'est pas bien et c'est les citations
de le pen et c'est ceux ci et c'est cela
et c elysée par recettes et patient news
à l'époque mais c'était l'idée
zemmour c'est tous ces gens qui parlent
mal et c'est eux qui ont nourri ce
fameux breivik et puis après cette
amérique breivik n'était pas breivik et
que c'était un phénomène que jean luc
mélenchon ne veut pas voir si vous
voulez qu'ils auraient d'ailleurs c'est
toujours pour inventer quelque chose
alors il confond les musulmans les
islamistes c'est son problème c'est
toujours pour inventer pour dire du mal
des musulmans et je dire alors là tout
d'un coup la lame et seul intérêt c'est
beaucoup moins et d'ailleurs il faut
dire ah là là là
d'ailleurs il faut dire que toute la
classe politique on était en pleine
élection présidentielle on a sousse
toute la société française
assou réagi à la paire mme merah il n'y
a pas une manifestation
il n'y a pas eu des drapeaux en berne il
n'y a pas eu toutes ces choses qu'on a
fait ensuite pour charlie et cetera on a
été extrêmement soft est d'ailleurs moi
je m'en veux encore de cela parce que
c'était quand même un crime terrible est
épouvantable si vous voulez et moi cette
phrase je veux bien croire que je les
sais pas comme moi qu'il est mal
comprise c'est lui qui s'est mal
expliquée mais quand il dit tout ça
c'est bateau c'est une phrase thériault
lancé moi ce que j'attendais aujourd'hui
que jean luc mélenchon c'est qu'ils
disent excusez moi j'aurais pas dû dire
ça au lieu de quoi annoncer les
complotistes anti complotistes
et comme d'habitude s'il n'a pas gagné
s'il n'a pas gagné s'il fait ce score et
que le froid le score du fn monte ça
n'est pas du tout à cause de la
situation
c'est à cause des autres c'est à cause
de ces news cet accord rien
vraisemblable alors moi cette affaire
pour moi est une bonne nouvelle parce
que je pense que jean luc mélenchon a
perdu sa crédibilité et j'en suis désolé
pour les autres insoumis qui sont obligé
de ramer comme des bêtes depuis 24
heures c'est vrai alors adrien justement
vous ramez d'abord cyril hanouna je vous
remercie de m'inviter je vous ai réservé
mes premiers mots ce soir évidemment à
toutes les victimes des attaques
terroristes et spécialement à madame
latifa benzia ten dont je sais que
l'émotion n'est pas feinte et qui
pourrait croire de par cette mauvaise
polémique qui a été organisée que jean
luc mélenchon soit mineur aurait
l'importance des attaques terroristes
soit croirez ou laisserait croire
qu'elle serait fomenté par des complots
politiques évidemment ce n'est pas le
cas et à toutes ces victimes et leurs
familles je veux dire que nous serons
toujours à leurs côtés
et j'ajoute
que jean luc mélenchon à chaque occasion
et chaque fois que le pays a été frappé
a été le responsable politique qui a eu
des paroles non seulement les plus
claires mais aussi les plus
pacificatrice par cyril hanouna vous
n'ignorez pas que tullow les terroristes
ont théorisé le fait que en plus de
leurs attaques et des morts qu'il
provoque
ils ont un objectif c'est que ce pays se
divise ils l'ont théorisé et jean luc
mélenchon et séverine à chaque étape a
fait en sorte de rappeler ces mots de
paix et de nécessité d'une image du
tabac comme une riposte ne rien verser
quelque sorte cyril hanouna le climat
que l'on voit et la pente glissante qu'a
pris ce pays participe en quelque sorte
du dessin des terroristes qui veulent
que l'on se divise alors chacun prend
ses responsabilités mais ses paroles et
les a toujours eu mélenchon ensuite et
3h50 ensuite terminé derrière maintenant
si vous posez la question aux
téléspectateurs comme à vos invités de
savoir s'ils sont d'accord pour dire que
lorsqu'il ya des attaques terroristes ou
des faits divers mais spécialement des
attaques terroristes elles peuvent être
instrumentalisé politiquement je pense
que tout le monde sera d'accord et
d'ailleurs qu'en france info a expliqué
que des chats avaient organisé les
attentats de londres en ce moment des
élections
personne n'a été tentée de dire que
france info faisait du complotisme quand
le journal dit indépendante britannique
disait que lors des attentats sur les
champs elysées c'est le policier qui a
été assassiné le 20 avril 2017
madame le pen tenté faire de la
récupération personne n'a dit même pas
eric naulleau ou madame lévy que le
journal généralement que j'osais du
groupe blood is lutte
donc si vous voulez une nouvelle fois
parce qu'il a notamment une question
qu'on veut toujours éviter que la
question jean luc mélenchon a évoqué
pendant 45 minutes dans cette émission
il ne reste que 30 secondes aujourd'hui
à mais c'est la question sociale
eh bien on a une nouvelle fois une
polémique auxerre est organisé alors
j'ajoute déjà chef les gens qui
regardent déjà le chef sur l'horizon
qu'il est quand même assez préoccupant
de voir que le jour où dans ce pays il y
un homme d'extrême droite qui a mis en
scène dans une vidéo à l'exécution d'un
militant politique en chasse un
contre-feu dans une forme
mais moi moi personnel alors que ça
n'inquiète pas les gens mais surtout il
n'y a pas de lien entre les deux vous
parlez de contre-feux mais je dire nous
on fait aucun lien entre la polémique
qui a été organisé et le fait que cette
vidéo d'extrême droite ait été publiée
hier c'est vous écoute je viens cette
deuxième chance vous parler de sujets
divers
je vais résumer aussi pour les
téléspectateurs en fait pour vous jean
luc mélenchon
il a dit quoi il a dit que à chaque fois
qu'on se rapprocher d'une échéance
présidentielle
il y avait des attentats il a pas dit
attendez ça me consterne exactement des
attaques d'anders les accédants sont
attendus très bon d'entendre monsieur 80
se dire enfin le moins attentats puisque
seront dans la bouche de monsieur les
désastres du modem jean iliad il ya des
personnes qui disent il a voulu dire que
c'était instrumentalisé que ce n'est pas
vrai d'avancis d'abord je voudrais dire
que ça n'est en aucun cas un dérapage
ce sont des déclarations qui
s'inscrivent dans une double continuité
la première continuité c'est le naufrage
intellectuelle et républicains de jean
luc mélenchon qui est devenu la
caricature de lui-même et la deuxième
continuité c'est pousser jusqu'au bout
la logique de l'islamo gauchisme
quel est l'âge de logique de l'islamo
gauchisme c'est de dire en fait les
attentats antisémites commis par des
extrémistes islamistes c'est pas
vraiment ça c'est organisé parce que les
airs et lévis a été très modérée moi ce
que j'ai entendu ce que des millions de
français entendu c'est ce sont des
attentats organisés par des gens
désignés par le système ça c'est très
pratique le système parce qu'on sait les
petits c'est mal écrit
c'est ça c'est ça pour nous c'est ce
qu'il dit évidemment qu'il notamment
dans l'extrait que nous avons motazé il
ya quelques instants exactement nambotin
midi c'est exact autre chose tel match
c'est quelque chose alisation candice
heck
l'instrumentalisation c'est évidemment
le seul argument que vous pouvez
présenter vous ne pouvez pas dire le
contraire simplement je voudrais vous
dire que jean luc mélenchon ça fait
longtemps qu'il est complètement indigne
de la fonction qu'il brigue
c'est le président de la république là
il en est devenu totalement a dit method
man de rome
vous dis à vous ce que j'ai dit alexis
corbière caraquet mairie nous connaît
bien il est temps de vous débarrasser du
bébé ou parce que vous êtes une secte
est prisonnier des délires de cet homme
tire de loin est mort mais oui les
annonces et on sait pas quoi me
répondent on parle de zemmour mais moi
je parle de mélenchon 0 il a rien à voir
dans cette affaire ne m'emballe pas si
tôt demain mais attention cette vidéo
car ce qu'a dit jean luc mélenchon est
gravissime parce que c'est de
l'ultrabook l'autisme rétabli laissé
entendre dès 1910 donc vous mais
millions de français ont entendu le jean
luc mathieu dire que les attentats
absolument ploéven n'aurait absolument
pas son sol et entendu des instruments
tels le système organisait des actes
envers ils repassent à la hausse est le
résultat des élections et témoignerait
par 2,6 alors par deux mois j'ai entendu
la même chose
et franchement je trouve l'explication
de nous dire que c'était pas ça a ses
limites mais très bien à dos les
attendait mais moi j'ai pardon je vais
finir maintenant alors oui ça c'est vu
que je vais pas m'énerver mais j'ai une
grosse voix donc je vais finir ma phrase
et donc j'ai entendu les explications je
n'y crois pas vraiment mais même
admettons qu'il n'ait pas voulu dire ça
et qu'il est juste voulu parler de la
surmédiatisation pardonnez moi en 2004
le pardonner mois en demi lune en 2000
cas en 2012
il n'a absolument pas là au contraire
tout le monde a fait attention je me
rappelle un grand édito de frau zabel
rouge juste au même moment expliquant
que c'était horrible que c'était la
libération de la parole et puis tout
d'un coup quand il s'est avéré que
c'était mais rappelez personnes et la
campagne de 2015 n'a absolument pas eu
lieu sur les attentats on avait une demi
on avait une double 250 morts et au
contraire parce qu'à ce moment-là macro
était quasiment mélenchonistes sur ces
questions culturelles identitaires
islamistes et cetera il voulait pas le
boire y a pas de culture française
c'était ça l'idée
si vous voulez donc inapte la campagne
de 2012
au contraire nous n'en avons pas assez
parlé mais moi c'est une pièce que vous
auriez vous ça veut dire quoi sur
médiatisé ça veut dire que quand on va
tuer des enfants juifs dans une école
tracadie un macaque on a peur dans les
boîtes mails change on est dire l
instrumentalisation politique voulani
eric poulat là mais pas qu'on ne sent
pas de 3g dit qu'il fallait pas jouer
alors on en parle tout le contraire mais
nous en parlons ces mêmes services
qu'eric de l'autorité d'eric naulleau
par eric naulleau laissez moi parler
s'il voit s'écrouler
c'est que vous avez déclaré que vous
exécrez tout ce qui se rapporte à la
france en sont mises aux enchères sont
soumises qui veut pas débattre avec moi
plus normal quand je l'avais déclaré que
ce soit aujourd'hui que je puisse vous
répondre jean luc mélenchon en 2015
était le soir même sur un plateau dont
tout le monde se souvient je vous invite
à aller voir la vidéo
à côté d'edouard philippe d'ailleurs sur
un plateau où il était très clair sur
ces questions il a toujours été
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui a fait
lever tout le monde à l'assemblée
nationale quand monsieur le
lieutenant-colonel arnaud beltrame s'est
sacrifié vous en rappelez quand même de
ces mots vous ne pouvez pas dire qu'il
n'a jamais été clair au contraire sur
ces sujets il passe aujourd'hui
centralisons eric naulleau simplement et
vous ne pouvez pas le contester c'est en
fait d'ailleurs plein de médias dont
vous n'oserez pas dire qu'ils sont
complotistes le disent c'est que
évidemment ces attentats et d'ailleurs
mais les commanditaires eux mêmes assume
le fait qu'ils choisissent leurs moments
had a bien évidemment pas imposer
notamment les deux minutes à la racaille
et juste quand quand vous entendez tous
les deux cette sortie de jean luc
mélenchon que vous voyez que ça buzze
énormément qu'est ce qui se dit au
parquet ce que je vous appelle jean luc
mélenchon vous lui dites jean-luc
sortira peut-être tu as peut-être les
connais où est ce que oui ou non on est
d'accord avec toi
ou bien est-ce qu'ils lui vouent dit il
ce qui vous dit d'aller sur des plateaux
essayer d'arracher une histoire comment
ça se passe à sylla nous avons envie de
savoir chanter hanouna mais c'est vrai
je veux dire on vous a fait vous l'avez
eue jean-luc mélangez bien sûr mais bien
parce que je dois vous dire c'est que
dans cette période vous le voyez bien
parfois tenir quelques positions de
principe et compris quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé avec la tribune des
militaires où aucun responsable
politique ne réagit quand on voit la
manifestation qui a eu 17 laquelle sa
d'organisation beauté à la gare 100
d'accord en dise que la justice est
terrible m devant l'assemblée nationale
mais arrêtez de faire diversion et la
salle rc pas vous fait diversion
voir l'éducation est un sujet bien sûr
mais le sujet le sujet est claire jean
luc mélenchon a toujours été très clair
s'agissant des menaces terroristes
seraient de la manière dont il fallait y
riposter il a toujours répété encore
récemment sur un plateau mais bien sûr
eric naulleau ne leur a pas entendu ne
voudra pas l'entendre jean luc mélenchon
verbatim il ya quelques jours quelques
semaines de ça sur lci
chez melick harware dire clairement les
islamistes politiques doivent savoir que
moi et mes amis c'est du jean luc
mélenchon seront toujours la zad
berrabah oui ils ont bien vu mais
veulent mais parce que madame vous voyez
pas madame lévis on se connaît pas je
vous ai jamais vu mais quand je regarde
un peu vos déclarations j'ai tout à
l'heure vous parler fort oui quand vous
parlez fort pour parler de ceux qui ont
une tête d'arabe et tout le reste comme
on vous entend faire et vous participé
sans le vouloir d'ailleurs un dessin qui
est celui des terroristes je restais
parler d'autre chose je vous non je ne
pars pas d'autre ce que j'ai entendu ça
laissez le parler de la guerre de troie
c'est à dire partir une stratégie pour
fausser messianisme moi c'est ce que
j'ai entendu courage de gaudi
solidariser les coloris ral eric les
lots attendent le chaland cheville et
cette honnêteté écoutez moi
jean luc mélenchon n'a jamais minorer
ses actes mais vous millions d'eur dit
qu'ils étaient un complot politique
si en revanche si vous voulez six ans
nous sortirons de ce plateau eric
naulleau vous montrer une vidéo qui date
de ce week-end sans faute dans les
locaux du front national en paca où il
ya une discussion stratégique où on dit
comment on utilise on instrumentalise
les mots lui coûter cher ami je n'ai pas
donc j'ai droit à l'indignation
hémiplégie alors et gagner alors nous
sommes d'accord
vous êtes d'accord
j'aimerais vous poser une question et la
poser à tout le monde ici est ce qu'on
n'a pas entendu dans parfois des gens
dire et des hauts responsables et même
des dégâts qui sont au rez de des gaves
et voilà je joue dit dgac sont raides
des gars qui sont gign
les mecs qui vous disent attention on va
être en période électorale
attention il ya des risques d'attentats
pourquoi on me dit ça gilles verdez dans
les séries on dit cela parce que
effectivement ce que sur sur le fond il
ya des auteurs d'attentats des gens qui
préparent des attentats pour
déstabiliser
à ce moment là en pleine campagne
électorale et au camp dit laissez-moi
finir non mais les serristes non mais y
aura toujours des services de
renseignement et les forces de l'ordre
savent très bien que certains utilisent
ces périodes là pour déstabiliser la
fronde est ce qu a voulu d'urgence et
mélenchon et sur la marque nationale
il a dit que ce système sur le candidat
macro nana d'emplacements tellement bon
c'est un fait que les personnes qui nous
attaquent le font avec un agenda avec
voilà un calendrier c'est pas nous qui
le disons ce sont des chercheurs tu
viens de dire là dessus c'est une
évidence pour appliquer ce qui veut dire
pour vous dire qu'il va dire que nous
les citoyens au moment d'une élection
notamment présidentielle lorsque ce qui
est en jeu c'est notre souveraineté à
nous nous devons intégrer le fait que
effectivement nos ennemis choisi cette
époque deuxièmement ils sont en vigueur
en fait si tu y arrives à charles gimat
nous quittons pas ce qu'est la démo
l'eau il a dit le système
je voudrais alors et matthew martin
etongue tu veux des choses on peut
repasser ça nous devons nous les
citoyens être en alerte par rapport aux
manipulations qui viennent sur les gens
violents soient des partis politiques
soit de leurs représentants dans les
médias que vous êtes
parce que là depuis contre tout à
l'heure qu'on vous écoute vous n'avez
pas un mot pour les victimes vous
la france joue les musulmans mais vous
dire c'est fait vous devriez moi je suis
très content que ce matin j'ai pensé à
madame sinclair et je me suis dit je
suis contente d'avoir le jeu vous me
laisser finir donc j'avais à lui dire ma
chère raquel moi je suis très triste des
juristes je te des juifs qu'ils
affrontent à cause de l'antisémitisme et
c'est pas celui d'extrême droite
contrairement à ce que vous voulez nous
raconter encore une manie devait moore
il avait rien dit sur papa c'est au café
un appel au meurtre avant pendant deux
ans je n'ai jamais parlé de ce que je
veux c'est fini tu sais pas mais moi dit
et moi je viens des soucis madrid
vous êtes-vous l'émir et l'extrême
droite voudrait mais service après vente
autorisés ont résonné dans la foulée
jean loup dijon mais pas oublier cible
parce que c'est trop facile vous croyez
vous avez marre pressio n'est donc pas
du même interrompre est ce que vous
allez perdre de temps on voulait pas 40
mais les gens matin je me suis dit que
j'étais je suis toujours très triste des
juifs quittent la france mais là je suis
contente de savoir que cette dame n'est
plus en france pourquoi elle est plus en
france parce qu'en 2014 à tarse r on
criait mort aux juifs sous sa fenêtre
je ne vous ai pas beaucoup entendu
là-dessus mais peu importe maintenant je
vais vous répondre sur mélenchon
moi je vais donner le bénéfice du doute
un peu par courtoisie mais en fait je
n'y crois pas sa phrase
tout ça c'est bateau et je vais vous
dire à vous et faites les élections de
2000 vous allez les émotions fait les
élections de 2017 aurait dû se faire sur
les attentats parce qu'il ya une chose
qui vous avertit mental il ya des choses
qui vous échappe
vous vous apercevrez mentaliser
s'intéresser à autre chose qui intéresse
qui inquiète les français à l'effort au
jardin son score aux élections étaient
vraiment les sondages vous fêter sainte
chapelle sont plus laxistes
regardez les sondages attentats et reid
avant ce week-end et jean luc mélenchon
tous ces propos sont tous les yeux